secretary state is speaking let's listen
in this is uh my fourth trip to Israel
since the horrific Hamas attacks of
October
7th so I'm here uh just over three
months 95 days since those attacks
occurred we know that for the people who
are most affected by the attacks and the
conflict that's followed uh time moves
different
ly uh immediately before this I met with
the families of hostages being held in
Gaza and with hostages who been
released several of those families I've
now met multiple
times for
them every day every hour every minute
that they're separated from their loved
ones is an
eternity time feels different for
families in Gaza as well hundreds of
thousands of whom are experiencing acute
food
insecurity for the mother or father
trying to find something to feed a
hungry child the passage of another day
without food is
excruciating time also feels different
for Israelis and Palestinians whose
innocent loved ones have been killed for
them time often falls into before and
after
the after filled with a loss that most
of us will never
know and cannot fully
imagine and those are just a few
examples of how heavy these 95 days have
felt and continue to feel for the people
most affected by this
conflict this immense human
toll is one of the many reasons that we
continue to stand with Israel in
ensuring that October 7th can never
happen
again it's also why we're intensely
focused on bringing the remaining
hostages home addressing the
humanitarian crisis and strengthening
protection for civilians in Gaza and
preventing the conflict from spreading
and it's the reason we're working
urgently to forge a path toward lasting
peace and Security in this
region we believe the submission against
Israel to the international court of
justice distracts the world from all of
these important
efforts and moreover the charge of
genocide is
meritless it's particularly gin given
that those who are attacking Israel
Hamas Hezbollah the houthis as well as
their supporter Iran continue to openly
call for the annihilation of Israel and
the mass murder of
Jews on this trip I came to Israel after
meeting with the leaders of of Turkey
Greece Jordan cter the United Arab
Emirates Saudi
Arabia all of those leaders share our
concern about the spread of the conflict
all of them are committed to using their
influence using the ties that they have
to prevent it from escalating to deter
new from
opening in addition all Express great
concern about the dire humanitarian
situation and the number of civilians
killed in
Gaza we know that facing an enemy that
embeds itself among civilians who hides
in and fires from schools from hospitals
makes this incredibly
challenging but the daily toll on
civilians in Gaza particularly on
children is far too
high important progress has been made in
increasing the amount of Aid getting
into Gaza including by opening corm
alone nonetheless 90% of gaza's
population continues to face acute food
inse security according to the United
Nations for children the effects of long
periods without sufficient food can have
lifelong
consequences as I underscored in our
meetings today more food water more
medicine other essential Goods need to
get into Gaza and then once they're in
Gaza they need to get more effectively
to the people who need them uh and
Israel needs to do everything it can to
remove any obstacles uh from Cross
things to other parts of Gaza improving
deconfliction procedures to ensure that
the aid can move safely and securely is
a critical part of
that the United Nations is playing an
indispensable role in addressing the
immense humanitarian needs in Gaza uh
there is simply no
alternative un personnel and other Aid
workers in Gaza are demonstrating
extraordinary Courage by continuing to
provide life-saving services in what are
extremely challenging conditions um I
spoke last night with the un's new
senior humanitarian and reconstruction
coordinator for Gaza sigd Cog uh about
all of these efforts that are
underway now Sig kaga someone I worked
very closely with uh a few years ago
when she led the UN mission that
destroyed the Assad Rim's chemical
weapons in Syria so I can say from
experience she has what it takes to get
this job done she has America's full
support she must have Israel's as
well today we also discussed the phe
transition of Israel's military campaign
in Gaza we continue to off for our best
advice for how Israel can achieve it's a
central goal of ensuring that October
7th can never be repeated and we believe
Israel has achieved significant progress
toward this fundamental objective as
Israel's campaign moves to a lower
intensity phase in Northern Gaza and as
the IDF scales down its forces there we
agreed today on a plan for the UN to
carry out an assessment Mission uh it
will determine what needs to be done to
allow displace paltin Palestinians to
return safely to homes in the
north now this is not going to happen
overnight there are serious security
infrastructure and humanitarian
challenges but the mission will start a
process that evaluates these obstacles
and how they can become uh be
overcome in today's meetings I was also
uh Crystal Clear Palestinian civilians
must be able to return home as soon as
conditions allow they must not be
pressed to leave Gaza as I told the
Prime Minister the United States
unequivocally rejects any proposals
advocating for the resettlement of
Palestinians outside of Gaza and the
Prime Minister reaffirmed to me today
that this is not the policy of Israel's
government we also spoke about the
tensions on Israel's northern border
with Lebanon where Hezbollah continues
to launch daily rocket attacks on
Israel as I told the war cabinet and
other senior officials the United States
stands with Israel is and ensuring its
northern border is secure we're fully
committed to working with Israel to find
a diplomatic solution that avoids
escalation and allows families to return
to their homes to live securely in
Northern Israel and also in southern
Lebanon finally we continue to discuss
how to build a more durable peace and
security for Israel within the region as
I told the Prime Minister every partner
that I met on this trip said that
they're ready to support a lasting
solution that ends the long running
cycle of violence and ensures Israel's
security but they underscored that this
can only come through a regional
approach that includes a pathway to a
Palestinian
State these goals are attainable but
only if they're pursued
together this crisis is clarified you
can't have one without the other and you
can't achieve either goal without an
integrated Regional approach
to make this possible Israel must be a
partner to Palestinian leaders who are
willing to lead their people and living
side by side in peace with Israel uh and
as neighbors and Israel must be must
stop taking steps that undercut
Palestinian ability to govern themselves
effectively extremist settler violence
carried out with impunity settlement
expansion demolitions evictions all make
it harder not easier for Israel to
achieve lasting peace and
security the pal
Authority also has a responsibility to
reform itself to improve its governance
issues I plan to raise with President
abas among others when we meet
tomorrow if Israel wants its Arab
neighbors to make the tough decisions
necessary to help ensure its lasting
security Israeli leaders will have to
make hard decisions
themselves when President Biden
addressed the people of Israel uh days
after the October 7th attack he made a
very simple pledge the United States has
Israel back today tomorrow
always the friendship between our
Nations is truly
exceptional it's our unique Bond and
America's enduring commitment to the
people of Israel that allows indeed
demands that were as forthright as
possible in the moments when the stakes
are highest when the choices matter the
most this is one of those moments